thank you
[Music]
all right this is sort of sad
um actually it's extremely sad why did I
say sorted you're gonna this is gonna
break your heart ready
yeah there's my why are you mess with my
cupcake everyone's yelling at me I'm so
there's this 19 year old girl
and uh
she's her behavior starts changing and
her parents are kind of like what's
going on with her she starts to like
lose her General enthusiasm for things
not laughing as much her grades she was
getting straight A's and then goes to a
failing level wow
um she just couldn't get out of bed and
they suspected that it was
um what's it called it was like a side
effect of Kobe you know long covet yeah
yeah so that was brain fog turns out so
she's 19 and it turns out She's
suffering from dementia oh oh wow like
one of the youngest cases ever holy
what trigger did do they say or not I
think it was cultured mushrooms they
think they think it could be stemming
from a like a car accident that she was
in they don't know for sure but she's
she's getting dementia so quickly to the
level of uh she doesn't even know like
she doesn't knows that she has anything
wrong with her so she her uh her
mentality actions are deviating into
total apathy she just does nothing wow
because it just like hit so fast does
she eat and stuff or like normal human
barely yeah she can't she can't remember
how to do anything oh my God isn't that
so extreme like she's just she's just
all the information and doubt is just
like dude that's inaccessible in her
brain that's one of my biggest fears
then that's a tremendous negative into a
positive she'd be really good at
meditating
God damn
God damn it we can't win with that
argument on this side that's am I am I I
think I should run with that let's hear
it all right now I have to support turn
it into a point so this is why Ken's
right
so if she was Buddhist you think she
would reach yes because literally she
started just sit there and you just well
she's white okay Ken I don't know if she
can't focus for that long
yeah I don't think she could focus for
that long don't you think yeah
you do have to focus but you don't have
to
not think of anything what happens
so look if I my intention of meditating
is I'm sitting upright and I fall asleep
in the middle of my meditation am I
still meditating no you're just you can
meditate in your sleep
I haven't done it but it's a thing how
would you know huh you are aware so that
you're not sleeping then well because
you know how you can be aware okay let's
just move on
comment below what you think that's
Advanced Buddhism yes moving on how
advanced is Buddhism where you can
sit in your style and then jump off jump
up into the into the sky that's like
first level yeah very soon
you can like just jump sitting Indian
style and I saw a shot do that I was
like yeah
dude you could even do it you could even
do a backflip from sitting Indian style
you know what I mean I just want to jump
out of a pool yeah and like just land
outside last time
how's your memory is I mean 19 is when
it started she's 20 now but does she
know who she is still probably not so
she's she doesn't know anything she
doesn't do anything is it bad to wonder
would it be like to date her no no
because you'd probably get her hit Adam
Sandler movie out of it right
[Laughter]
the glasses go on dude
yeah but um yeah they think she she was
in a car crash that compressed discs in
her neck so that could be linked to it
bro the brain is fragile dog yeah you
just never know what it's gonna do you
think a chiropractor would help in that
situation I think he would say he could
help yeah
family Drive
here take these essential oils and rub
it on the base of your neck a lot of the
insurance covered it the chiropractor
can do no wrong you don't want to be
crazy if like a miracle happened and she
just like randomly started or her
parents suggested her to do whatever
medicine and just
the opposite happened where she has such
a great memory that she retains so much
information like people who can much
people who could like look through a
book and
and yeah the what they just read that's
with it like she could tap into more of
her brain right it just completely
slingshots the other way yeah I mean if
there's still no treatment are there
ever any cases of people recovering from
dementia I don't think so they've never
had so much work that's being done but
it's it's interesting this is definitely
one of the younger cases ever there's
currently no cure and um because and
they said it's unlikely that they there
can be a single cure because dementia is
caused by so many different diseases and
every every neuroscientist in the world
always says we don't know anything about
the brain so essentially dementia is
just certain things turning off in the
brain or what like it's it's like a kind
of like a brain deadness yeah in a way
but they said like once you're diagnosed
with it your life expectancy from that
point is around eight to ten years holy
crap is it because they just stopped
doing whatever and they don't eat they
don't and then your quality of life was
without things that you can you know
remember or have some sort of foundation
with it's just every function in your
body needs your brain can you also just
like die from it is that a thing I don't
know just like I think so better just
like the other things from not oh you
die as a result of like a movement like
her parents I'm assuming they're
practical parents they're probably
trying everything that they hear yeah
like oh hey there's try this ancient
blah blah blah go try this meditation go
try the chiropractor they're probably
doing everything possibly also because
she's young maybe there could be a shot
is that because like maybe her yeah does
your brain keep developing until you're
25 because yeah most people that get
dementia are like 80 or 90s right yeah
so did you say she was an accident or
was that she was up in my mind she was
in a car accident that the compressed
her discs but they don't know if that's
correlated because it's not like it
happened right after right like she was
fine for a while Adventure is also a
genetic too right is it I think it is I
think we're not scientists here or
doctors well a lot of brains I'll just
answer that um yeah I think so I think
sometimes it is genetic sometimes it's
not yeah
imagine it's just clearly not I stayed
at a Hollywood in Express last night
what is the difference between dementia
and Alzheimer's that's a good question
the name
dementia is a general term for a decline
in mental ability Alzheimer's is the
specific disease okay so so Alzheimer
could fall under dementia yeah yeah
Alzheimer's is a type of dementia oh
dementia is the general term for decline
of cognitive ability dang yeah so it's
the process so it's a generalized yeah
so because there's so many functions oh
Alzheimer's is hard to pinpoint what it
is a type of dementia
it's like saying it's like saying muscle
atrophy versus versus random or
something yeah oh okay maybe yeah I
didn't hear you so I think Alzheimer's
is a type of dementia right thank you
guys let's say this one more time
everybody around send it home sit home
do you understand so like dementia is
like the umbrella Alzheimer would be
under the umbrella are you sure
she looks cool too that's her that's
Gianna oh and she's just like sad bro 20
she's 20 now and like imagine that dude
how heartbreaking is that to be a parent
and then your kid at 19. just can't like
process anything what do you do bro like
what do you do I mean at least she's
alive I guess sort of an upside but like
are you really you know what if she had
Asian parents oh man imagine that
because like even like when you're
already doing stuff your Asian parents
don't think it's enough yeah oh my God
she's probably not doing enough are you
saying she's getting beat by her Asian
parents because what if they don't
understand it I don't understand yeah
you're just being lazy wake up yeah yeah
like because they don't they'll clear
your room why are you just sitting there
dude you want to hear you want to hear
the freaking worst thing what oh the
um her mom goes I recently asked her
what's the happiest moment of your life
she just looked confused and said I
don't remember
that's you know that's what I was
thinking is it was even harder more
difficult for appearances
she can't the parents can't offer a
bucket list of things for her to do
before she dies yeah exactly she doesn't
know she says no she's doing anything
yeah
so they're just sitting there helpless
but that's why I'm saying like with
meditation it's not about doing what
you're gonna do right it's just what's
going on right now that's very I think
to me so that's like probably the
closest thing meditation might be too
high level for her too maybe kind of
like well we don't know yeah no I'm
saying for someone with dementia like
you have to explain it and you have to
explain it again and then she has to be
able to connect the dots but not with
the cool app of headspace can you
imagine if a doctor if she went to like
a Vietnamese doctor and he's like I'm
gonna prescribe you eight milliliters of
uh Buddhism oh dang give him some books
check it out some books books read about
Buddhism
they're just like there's nothing they
can do the mom's just like I pray
there's a treatment there's nothing like
we already know because what's sadness
she probably doesn't know why she's here
but then the Kent could verbalize yeah
like but is she conscious like is she
there like it's it's like it's like it's
kind of like a half and half because
it's like you're aware that you're alive
but as soon as you realize you're alive
you forgot you realized it so it's like
a general like Loop of that's why they
say she's just completely apathetic
because she doesn't bother doing like a
blank slate almost but she's still yeah
it's like she why bother doing something
when you thought of doing it and then
you forgot to do it and you don't know
you did it but there is also like an
upside of like well at least you you
won't remember like all the bad stuff
that you feel either you know what I
mean like she won't feel sad about it
because she will forgot that it even
happened it's like so extreme that like
it's like nothing exists bro if I'm ever
in that state just put a pillow in my
face but how would you until I stopped
stop kicking are you on that boat of
like plug pull me oh dude if I there's
no shot no shot nobody could ever say
there's no shot I mean what if you what
if this could be like the first miracle
case like because she's so young that
yeah something could uh if they're
regenerating if there's somebody to
Rally behind
um if there's somebody a cure for this
yeah
if there's somebody to Rally behind and
to like throw spaghetti on the wall you
deal with this girl you know what I mean
yeah throw spaghetti in the walls even
sticks oh make sure it's al dente
no